hey guys what's up this is andrew for
10senses.com so in this video guys we're
gonna go through yesterday's press
action on amc we're gonna see what
happened we finished the day almost in
the green but the candle we have is a
hammer it's a green candle it's a
reversal candle so let's analyze
everything that happened on friday and
see what can happen next let's get into
it
[Music]
oh right guys so here we go amc chart
daily time frame let me remove the
bollinger bands for now so let me
quickly sum up what i was saying in my
last video and then i'm saying on my
discord guys
every day for quite some time is that we
were not ready to rebound we needed to
see a strong victory of bulls we needed
to see some negative data taking place
with the market from becoming from
margin calls guys and we've seen this i
think for the first time on friday so i
was waiting to see all the signals that
usually occur in a reversal before
turning bullish and i'm bullish on the
long run but you guys know that for on
the short term i was not that bullish
for the past few weeks since we broke
out from this triangle here guys it was
just were in full control so what
happened here first let's analyze what
the information we get from the momentum
so as you can see i have here the rsi
and here the macd we have the market
here between
december 14th and now making lower lows
all right we went from 20 to 16 and the
momentum is for now going higher i mean
not the rsi but the magazine so we have
a bit of a divergence bullish divergence
under magazine we don't have it on the
rsi
uh then let's see if this move is
complete or not because this is what we
need to know for reversal to happen we
first need the best to be satisfied so
are they satisfied i mean we can check
if the targets are reached so i measure
we are i think in a y wave of the wxy
correction we are in for the past nine
months guys and in this y wave we're
developing doing an abc so the a wave is
here guys
a b c okay
and
we can measure the relation between the
a wave and the c wave applying fibs so
you measure the air wave you applied to
the top of the b wave and you see where
the fib ratio are bringing you so if i
do this here
i take this whole wave because this is
the maximum point i have here and i have
the 0.618 that is coming to 17.2 i mean
fibs are just areas this is roughly
where we went so
bears might be already full satisfied
they made enough money on the smooth
down so they would probably start to
take profit so i think that this is what
we have seen
look at what we have here guys i'm going
to analyze this move on the hourly
timeframe very soon but first we have
for the first time a green candle that
trapped a lot of bears because as you
can see here the tail is long we went to
16 we filled the gap guys there was a
gap here that got filled so in my
analysis i was saying that all the area
between 17 and 15 14.5 which is here you
can see we have some highs and in the
past i've shown you guys this already
before we had a lot of reaction at 14.5
as well here here you see in 2018 guys
all right so long time ago so this whole
area is a support area okay we went
there we filled the gap we bounced back
the move guys here is a ten percent move
i think right from the lows
to the close it's ten percent all right
so we just came up ten percent since the
middle of the day on friday so now i
think those are probably taking about
four shots and it's uh also magical so
i'm going to show you why so if you're
going to hourly time frame you're going
to i will literally film and you check
when was this rebound happening so i'm
in france right now so it was 4 p.m for
me so it was 10 a.m in the u.s so for me
it's uh 16 all right so 4 p.m all right
we have this massive move up okay now i
check on the i check the sp guys so by
the way go check my analysis yesterday
on the spy yes because this is all
related we are i think entering a
corrective phase we are in the a wave in
the sp why since we broke out from this
long term trend the b wave is coming so
the b wave is going to be bullish and if
the spy is bullish you know guys that
amc would be bullish but usually before
the strong run-ups on amc we see a
negative beta first happening i was
telling you guys that those margin calls
they happen whenever the global market
is breaking some levels that we don't
expect it to break right so that you
know surprise we are actually going
lower and so you guys hedge funds you
need to cut some of your positions that
consume a lot of margin like a short on
amc or gme by the way and here you can
see this level is four four one all
right four four one is the 200 day
moving average everybody was saying
we're gonna rebound here okay i
personally had some short positions and
i still have some short position but i
took a little bit of profits what i mean
is i think the uh story is that we were
going through this level and then see
some marginal goals on amc and so 441 we
said
then i'm gonna leave them frame and yeah
exactly so this is why i was surprised
because it's a green candle but guys
it's a green candle that went through
four for one at what time at four p.m
all right france time so we went through
then we rebounded true but first we went
through these levels for the first time
all right and this is exactly when amc
started to move up okay so you can check
it by yourself you're gonna see
so the negative beta two place guys you
remember when i posted that on twitter
okay you remember the spreadsheet it's
my spreadsheet guys and we've seen five
times in the past
uh we have seen strong moves up
occurring on amc when spy was breaking
some major levels all right so this is
what we're having actually right now
so here as you can see guys okay bam amc
okay i'm building the correlation guys
let me reduce the data
get bamboo bam look it's coming
oh right guys so you see this is my
chart and we have each time bam the
greens the green curve is the amc
monthly return that i smoothed because
i'm using the monster combination and i
just check whenever amc is moving
strongly up what is the correlation
doing and you can see the correlation in
blue is dropping amc is going up here
the correlation
for now it's not dropping it's positive
right it's positive because you don't
have the strong move up yet but let's
see what's gonna happen for now it's
positive because amc still was uh closed
the day negatively yesterday so it's a
positive correlation but
we have this information all right so we
have the information that uh we wanted
to see this negative bit almost negative
beta we don't have it and the candle is
green so it's a hammer but we still
close the day negatively so it's not
perfect look at the volume i'm building
you calls guys by the way it's gonna be
amazing it's been like a few hundred
hours i'm working on it and it's gonna
come soon in this course it's about
breakouts i'm actually building a method
to know if we are in an environment
where breakouts are going to be
successful and for this you need to
analyze the volume the volatility and
the momentum so the momentum analysis i
just
did it all right we can see the market
making lower lows and the market for now
is not making the momentum is not making
higher lows i mean the macd is but not
the rsi so the momentum is not perfect
but it's okay then we can check if we
have some hidden bearish divergences all
right so be uh and we of course don't
want to see it so very skilled in that
divergence is whenever in a move down
here we're gonna move down the market
making low highs uh you have the
momentum that is making higher highs all
right so that's it's reloading energy
and that you can go lower and here we
don't have this momentum making higher
highs all right we have the momentum
making lower highs both on macd and on
our side does it mean the move down is
going to stop no it just means that we
are on a trend that is going too fast
too quickly without breathing on the
upside i mean the trend is going on
downside but we don't breathe on the
upside so it just means that does this
trend cannot be sustainable that at some
point is going to break all right and we
are monitoring what information can give
us this first signal of a trend shift
and a hammer reversal candle is one
information then we check the volume
very important
for a good reversal to happen we first
need to have low volume then increasing
volume on the upside okay so here we
have those slow volumes i mean we have
here the strong volume on the last day
but we don't have the low volume before
what does it mean it means that i think
we might have some nice move-ups coming
maybe tomorrow i mean on monday maybe
you know plus 10 plus 20 percent maybe
something like this but i'm i think like
the most important trend line is this
one we probably gonna need some time to
consolidate you can check the volatility
as well guys this is very important to
know if we are ready to reverse for now
look at the bollinger bands they are
widening all right we want to see them
narrowing you can check each time before
every strong reversal they are very
narrow here very narrow here very narrow
okay it's like this when they are not
narrow it just means that there's going
to be more ups and downs but now i think
an up is coming but then we're probably
going to consolidate to conclude
negative beta almost here strong day
strong volume on the day of a hammer
candle that is a reversal candle we fill
the gap the burst might be satisfied the
fib ratio are telling us that it might
be the end of this move down once again
it might as well go to 15 i don't think
we will go to 15 now i personally sold
some 15 puts on february and bought some
25 calls so that even if we close at 16
on the 18th of february i didn't lose
money on this trade and if it was
strongly higher i make money so this is
i think a nice trade to do
selling the 15 puts instead of buying
shares and yeah and we want to see this
breakout happening guys uh so it's going
to be around 22. okay this is the
important level and ideally we would
like some consideration on low volume
first and then a breakout on strong
volume right increasing volume this is
what we need to happen for amc to make a
sustainable reversal i'm gonna update
you later on what's gonna happen next
but basically my scenario is i don't
think we go to 15 anymore all right i
think we're done uh i think we reached
the lows i really do hope so
so my scenario is that we go here we can
say that we'll we break out we consider
it more then we come here
then here probably some up and down and
bam okay all right guys so it's been a
long way down i know guys i'm here i'm
with you guys i'm in the straight as
well i'm doing my best guys to give you
the best analysis i can
all right let's see i don't know what
will happen i just know that this
movement is still strong and that some
beautiful things are probably awaiting
us so thank you for watching this video
i hope you guys enjoyed it and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're going
to be the first to know when i plan
anything new and stay close to shore i
see you guys